in parchim in mecklenburg vorpommern
gibt ganz was besonderes ein angeblich
sehr edles mineralwasser gefördert aus
diesem 181 meter tiefen brunnen sage und
schreibe 18 euro kostet eine flasche gut
ein echter verkaufserfolg ist das luxus
wässerchen nicht im ersten
produktionsjahr werden gerade mal 3 173
flaschen verkauft
kein mensch bezahlt und irgendwie 18
euro für das ich würde niemals kaufen
und deshalb völlig überflüssig also mit
dem zeug machen sie keinen gewinnt
befindet sich nicht der knaller an der
sache die idee mit dem luxus wasser
hatten nicht eine private firma sie
kommt von den stadtwerken gemeinsam mit
partnern wird die - 181 gmbh gegründet
mit sitz auf dem gelände des städtischen
wasserwerks hier wird nicht gekleckert
sondern geklotzt internetauftritt
designer flasche alles nur vom feinsten
alles richtig teuer
bis ende 2018 fallen verluste in höhe
von 651.000 euro an
der landesrechnungshof hält die
beteiligung der stadt parchim an der
luxuswasser firma für gesetzeswidrig das
ist ein verstoß gegen die
kommunalverfassung ein öffentlicher
zweck muss gewahrt sein und hier ging es
ja um die produktion den vertrieb die
vermarktung eines luxus mineralwasser
ist einem eines mineralwassers in diesem
ultra premium segment das ist aus
unserer sicht garantiert kein
öffentlicher zweck
trotzdem verteidigt der geschäftsführer
der örtlichen stadtwerke zugleich chef
der edel wasser firma das
geschäftsmodell schriftlich heißt es
trotz anfänglicher probleme befanden
sich die in 2018 generierten verluste im
rahmen der ursprünglich geplanten
anlaufverluste wir glauben weiterhin an
das produkt sehen jedoch inzwischen die
kommunale beteiligung sehr viel
kritischer in parchim haben sie den
glauben an das örtliche luxuswasser
längst verloren
sie sollten sich auf das eigentliche
geschäft konzentrieren zu sind die
stadtwerke dass sie den bürgern von dem
leitungswasser liefern
sich zieht werde denn eigentlich jetzt
sich verantworten muss wenn ich das aber
richtig sehr plötzlich mir jeden tag die
zähne damit weil das ja wahrscheinlich
eigentlich das gleiche wasser ist unter
schmeckt ganz gut so richtig begeistert
ist die stadt allerdings mittlerweile
nicht mehr von ihrem abenteuer
luxuswasser sie will die firma loswerden
wenn sich niemand findet muss sie den
laden wohl dicht machen